el secretario general de naciones unidas
antonio guterres ha hablado de este
pacto como un faro de luz hacia la paz y
el presidente turco recep tayyp erdogán
se ha mostrado esperanzado pero ha dicho
que ha sido un pacto muy difícil se
trata del acuerdo llegado hoy mismo en
estambul entre rusia y ucrania para
permitir que en los próximos días en
rabia en palabras del propio erdogán
pueda empezar a exportar el trigo y
grano que había sido acumulado y
bloqueado en los puertos sucre más
después de que rusia y estableciese un
bloqueo naval tras la invasión rusa en
ucrania que empezó en febrero de este
mismo año la las negociaciones han
durado varios meses en culminado hoy en
estambul en una firma que ha sido en
parte dividida en dos sobre todo porque
los granas no querían firmar el mismo
documento de los rusos a la vez así que
primero el ministro de defensa ruso
serguéi tsoy lo ha firmado el documento
junto con erdogán y wolters después al
marcharse de la sala ha sido la
delegación ucraniana la que ha entrado
para firmar este mismo documento según
el texto al que iremos tienen acceso
después de esta firma este pacto tendrá
una duración de 120 días que serán
prorrogables si todas las partes lo
quieren
según el texto se establecerá en
estambul una comisión conjunta de todos
los países firmantes que velarán para
que este acuerdo se cumpla sobre todo
con dos grandes partes ucrania se
compromete a no utilizar los cargueros
que saldrán de ucrania para importar
armamento y munición desde países
occidentales a través del mar y rusia se
comprometerá a no bloquear estos navíos
que saldrán y a permitir su paso desde
los puertos ucranianos primero después
hacia el mar negro y después hacia el
estrecho del bósforo en la ciudad de
estambul algo este acuerdo permitirá
según todos los firmantes a eliminar y
evitar una crisis que se cernía sobre
muchos países africanos sobre todo y
también de oriente medio con unos
precios del trigo del grano muy altos
nuevas cafés que empezaba a ser
realmente preocupante para muchos países
del mundo según naciones unidas de este
pacto salvará las vidas de cientos de
miles o incluso millones de personas